this is a Fox News Alert I'm Bret Baier
in Washington we are an hour away from
what President Trump calls a major
statement by South Korea about North
Korea
the President himself delivering this
news about the news to reporters in the
briefing room a short time ago South
Korea is going to be making a major
statement and that was it kind of
cryptic chief White House correspondent
John Roberts starts us off tonight as
often with breaking news from the North
Lawn good evening John
good evening Brett and welcome back the
president did go on to say a little
further on in that exchange that the
announcement tonight would be about
North Korea we do not know what the
substance of that will be what we do
know that the president spoke with the
South Korean president moon jae-in today
about what was going on the North Korean
the South Korean rather National
Security Advisor is expected to be in
the Brady briefing room to deliver us
the news
he has been here all day along with his
staff talking with HR McMaster about
what happened earlier in the week
between North Korea and South Korea
where the North said that it would be
open to a meeting with moon jae-in and
this would be kim jong-min to south
korean territory to meet at the peace
house at the pan moon jom border
crossing which i know brett you're very
familiar with sometime in late May then
that could be the starting point for
direct talks between the United States
and North Korea what's interesting about
the president coming in is the first
time since he's been president 413 days
that he stuck his nose and his toes into
the briefing room didn't get all the way
in but quite a surprise to see him there
this announcement about North Korea from
South Korea comes out a day when the
president made his long-awaited
announcement on trade tariffs it's
something that the president has been
promising since the election campaign
today he did it the sanctions on
aluminum and steel are the first imposed
by the u.s. in 16 years president Trump
insisting they are necessary to protect
America's national security the strong
steel and aluminum industry are vital to
our national security absolutely vital
steel is steel you
steel you don't have a country but even
as he moved to punish nations he says
are unfairly dumping cheap steel into
the u.s. the president was talking about
carving out exclusions for certain
countries exempting Canada and Mexico at
least for now winning still we need
aluminium we're negotiating with Mexico
we're negotiating with Canada and the
NAFTA and depending on whether or not we
reach a deal also very much involved
with that is National Defense but if we
reach a deal it's most likely that we
won't be charging those two countries
the tariffs and there may be other carve
outs too for example a steel mill in
Sheffield England produces castings that
are used in the weapons system of the
new Colombia class nuclear submarines if
President Trump slaps tariffs on Britain
the US would be taxing its own supply
chain we have other countries that are
very much involved with us on trade but
also on military and working together
with military and we'll be making a
decision as to who they are but some of
America's European allies aligned under
the European Union trade collective are
planning retaliation is it I don't get
it
the European Commission is going to
introduce countermeasures to president
Trump's very inappropriate initiative
which might prove advantageous for the
United States right away but which in
the long run will harm the United States
influence in the world China which the
president has singled out for a
particularly bad behavior in dumping
steel suggested this might be the first
shot in a trade war poison in the event
of a trade war China will make a
justified and necessary response from
the Speaker of the House Paul Ryan this
afternoon a statement of opposition I
disagree with this action and fear it's
unintended consequences from the Senate
the man who said President Trump could
be the greatest president ever said he's
disappointed so I'm very upset about it
and frankly I love the president and I
just think he's been misled by some of
the people down at the White House but
from Kentucky aluminum worker James
Powell praised that the president is
willing to stick up for American steel
and jobs we're gonna bring back 300 jobs
over 300
I spent over 100 million dollars and I
plant alone in Kentucky so this is huge
for us one of the fiercest opponents of
tariffs inside the White House was chief
economic adviser Gary Cohn he attended
his last cabinet meeting today in a
farewell president Trump praising Cohn
but also taking the opportunity to roast
him just a little bit he may be a
globalist but I still like him it's
gonna go out and make another couple of
hundred million and then then he's gonna
maybe come back I don't know if I can
put him in the same position though it's
he's not quite as strong are those
tariffs as we want the president's
actually today starts a 15 day countdown
clock to the imposition of tariffs the
president is hoping that before then
some countries that he believes they're
bad actors will modify their trade
practices in order to avoid the punitive
sanctions right but quickly John as we
wait for this announcement from South
Korea on the trade issue the tariff
issue there is a lot of wiggle room
potentially here there is the president
was talking about the idea that Canada
and Mexico are initially excluded we
don't know how long that window will be
open for them he's also talking about
excluding some of our other allies who
are in the supply chain for national
security I don't think this is going to
go as far as it did back in 2002 when
the Bush administration had some 700
exemptions it made their tariff regime
look mostly like Swiss cheese more than
anything and proved that it was fairly
ineffective but they're definitely
thinking about carving out some
exclusions here China's not among them
though curious that's right all right
John thank you